>>> POLAND'S PREDENT SAYS IT
IS HARD TO DENY HIS WORDS
RUSSIAN FOES ARE COMMITTING
GENOCIDE IN UKRAINE.
THE GOAL OF THE VASION HE SAYS
IS, AND AGAIN THESE ARE HIS
WORDS, QUOTE TO SIMPLY
EXTINGUISH THE UKRAINIAN NATION.
HE SAID THAT IN AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW.
CNN'S DANA BASH JOINS US NOW
FROM WARSAW.
>> YOU KNOW, ANDERSON, THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY USES EVERY
OPPORTUNITY HE HAS WHETHER HE
SPEAKS TO A LEGISLATIVE BODY IN
ANY GIVEN COUNTRY OR DOES HIS
NIGHTLY ADDRESS TO SAY I NEED
MORE WEAPONS.
WELL, HERE IN POLAND, ITS
NEIGHBORING COUNTRY, THEY HAVE
WEAPON.
BUT THE QUESTION HAS BEEN
WHETHER OR NOT THIS COUNTRY,
POLAND, IS GOING TO GIVE THE
UKRAINIANS THOSE WEAPONS.
FOR A LOT OF REASONS NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH THERE IS FEAR
HERE ABOUT THEIR SECURITY SINCE
THERE HAS BEEN A THOUSAND-YEAR
ANIMOSITY BETWEEN THESE TWO
COUNTRIES.
SO THAT IS WHY YOU'LL HEAR IN
THIS INTERVIEW, ANDERSON,
PRESIDENT DOUDA, HERE IN POLAND
WAS RELUCTANT.
YOU TWEETED UKRAINIANS NEEDED
THREE THINGS ABOVE ALL, WEAPONS,
WEAPONS AND MORE WEAPONS.
YOU HAVE SOVIET ERA TANKS HERE
IN POLAND.
YOU HAVE SOVIET ERA AIRPLANES,
MIG 29s.
WHY HAVEN'T YOU BEEN ABLE TO
WORK WITH NATO TO GET THOSE TO
UKRAINE?
>> Translator: MADAM, I'M
SMILING BECAUSE WEAPONS, WEAPONS
AND MORE WEAPONS, THIS IS WHAT
UKRAINIANS NEED.
WE HAVE TO BE CLEAR TO THE FREE
WORLD THAT POLLS DO NOT EXPECT
THAT UKRAINIANS, OUR NEIGHBORS
WOULD BE SO DECISIVE AND SO
COURAGEOUS, EXCEPTIONALLY
COURAGEOUS AND THAT THEY WILL
DEFEND THEIR COUNTRY IN THIS
WAY.
MORE THAN 1 MILLION UKRAINIANS
BEFORE THE OUTBREAK OF THE WAR
WERE IN POLAND.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING HERE.
OF COURSE THEY VISITED THEIR
FAMILIES IN UKRAINE, BUT THEY
CAME BACK AND MADE MONEY IN
POLAND.
A VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE MEN
WENT TO UKRAINE TO FIGHT.
>> CAN NATO DO MORE TO HELP YOU
HELP THEM?
>> Translator: I CANNOT SAY
EVERYTHING, MADAM, HERE IN THIS
OPEN INTERVIEW BECAUSE THERE ARE
ALSO SECRETS, NATO SECRETS.
THERE ARE ALSO SECRETS BETWEEN
POLAND AND THE U.S.
HOWEVER, PLEASE BELIEVE ME.
I'VE TALKED TO PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN ABOUT THIS.
WE CONSULTED, AND THE U.S.
ADMINISTRATION IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND WE ARE IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH THE U.S.
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE IS HELP BEING PROVIDED.
IT COMES FROM THE UNITED STATES
AND ALSO COMING FROM OTHER
PLACES.
>> AND OF COURSE POLAND IS
ABSORBING MORE OF THE UKRAINIAN
REFUGEES BY FAR THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY SINCE THE WAR BEGAN,
OVER 2.5 MILLION REFUGEES AS YOU
KNOW.
HOW MUCH LONGER CAN YOUR COUNTRY
SUSTAIN THE VOLUME OF REFUGEES
AT THIS MAGNITUDE?
>> RIGHT BEFORE RUSSIAN ATTACK
ON UKRAINE PRIME MINISTER JUSTIN
TRUDEAU CALLED ME OF CANADA, AND
WE KNOW HE'S GOT A BIG
INFLUENTIAL AND UKRAINIAN
MINORITY IN HIS COUNTRY.
AND HE ASKED ME WHAT WE WOULD DO
IF THERE WAS A RUSSIAN ATTACK ON
POLAND.
I SAID I HAVE NO DOUBTS THE
BORDER WILL BE OPEN.
IF OUR UKRAINIAN NEIGHBORS ARE
ATTACKED, IF THEY FLEE FROM
DEATH, FROM WAR, FROM RUSSIAN
BOMBS OF COURSE WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE EVERYONE WHO NEEDS IT, AND
THAT IS WHAT WE DID.
WE OPENED OUR BORDER.
WE ACCEPTED EVERYONE.
THERE WAS A HUGE WAVE OF
REFUGEES.
IN THE FIRST TWO WEEKS OF THE
WAR WE HAD ALMOST 1.5 MILLION
UKRAINIAN REFUGEES, BUT THERE
WERE PEOPLE AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
FROM 170 DIFFERENT COUNTRIES ALL
OVER THE WORLD, 170, NOT ONLY
UKRAINIAN STUDENTS ALSO FROM
INDIA, FROM OTHER COUNTRIES,
FROM AFRICAN STATES.
A LOT OF THEM WE HAD A FULL
SPECTRUM OF PEOPLE.
ALL OF THEM WERE FLEE BECAUSE
THEY WERE AFRAID.
MANY HAVE LIVED IN KHARKIV WHERE
BOMBS WERE DROPPED ON LIVING
QUARTERS, ON APARTMENT BLOCKS,
SO WE ARE TAKING EVERYONE,
HOSTING EVERYONE AND TRYING TO
HELP EVERYONE.
OF COURSE THIS IS SOMETHING
POLAND HAS NEVER SEEN IN ITS
HISTORY.
WE'VE GOT MORE THAN 1,000 YEARS
OF HISTORY, BUT THIS SITUATION
IS UNPRECEDENTED.
WHEN WE RECEIVED 2.5 MILLION
PEOPLE IN DAYS IT'S
UNPRECEDENTED HISTORY.
WE ARE COPING WITH IT AND PROUD
OF OUR COMPATRIOTS.
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY REFUGEE CAMPS
IN POLAND.
SO FAR WE DID NOT HAVE TO BUILD
ANY REFUGEE CAMPS.
ALL THE PEOPLE WERE TAKEN TO
STUDENT HOME, IN HOTELS, IN
RESORTS, DIFFERENT PLACES MADE
AVAILABLE BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
SO WE'RE TRYING TO HELP AS GOOD
AS WE CAN, BUT WE NEED
INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT BADLY.
>> AND I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THAT
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WHAT THE POLISH PEOPLE ARE DOING
IS NOTHING SHORT OF REMARKABLE,
BUT THE U.S. CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS SAID THAT THIS
CONFLICT COULD TAKE YEARS.
SO ARE YOU STARTING TO PUT A
PLAN TOGETHER?
BECAUSE AS YOU SAID A LOT OF THE
UKRAINIANS ARE LIVING IN PEOPLES
HOMES.
ARE YOU STARTING TO PUT A PLAN
TOGETHER TO ABSORB THEM
OFFICIALLY INTO POLISH SOCIETY?
>> Translator: MANY OF THEM HAVE
REMAINED IN POLAND AND THEY'RE
STAYING IN POLAND.
FIRST AND FOREMOST THESE ARE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER ABOUT THIS.
MEN ARE FIGHTING.
UKRAINIAN BORDER GUARDS STOPPED
MEN AT THE BORDER.
THEY TOLD THEM TO COME BACK.
THEY JUST ALLOWED THE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN TO CROSS THE BORDER TO
POLAND.
THIS IS THE DECISION ON THE
U-I
UKRAINIAN SIDE.
WE HAVE SETUP SPECIAL LEGAL
REGULATION, ADOPTED A SPECIAL
ACTION AND A SPECIAL LAW WAS
ADOPTED WHICH GIVES THE SAME
RIGHTS TO THE UKRAINIANS AS THE
POLS HAVE, RIGHTS TO HEALTH
SYSTEM, EDUCATION, INSURANCE,
THE RIGHT TO WORK.
SO FAR IT IS BINDING FOR 18
MONTHS ON THOSE RIGHTS.
VERY MANY OF THEM ARE STAYING --
RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT ALMOST 2
MILLION REFUGEES IN POLAND.
MANY OF THEM DO NOT WANT TO GO
ANYWHERE ELSE.
THEY'RE SAYING WE WE ARE WAITING
UNTIL THE END OF WAR BECAUSE WE
WANT IT COME BACK TO OUR HOMES.
WOMEN WANT TO COME BACK TO THEIR
HUSBANDS, CHILDREN WANT TO COME
BACK TO THEIR SCHOOLS, THEIR
ENVIRONMENT.
WE WANT TO GIVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE CONDITIONS OF STAY HERE
IBPOLAND, AND WE HOPE THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO COME BACK WHEN THE WAR
IS OVER.
>> DANA, OBVIOUSLY THINGS ARE
FLUID.
DOES IT SOUND TO YOU LIKE
PRESIDENT DOUDA HAD ANY
LONG-TERM PLANS FOR THE REFUGEES
IN HIS COUNTRY?
>> Reporter: IN A LONG WORD, NO.
THIS HAPPENED SO QUICKLY, SO
ORGANICALLY.
BY THE WAY, THAT'S THE SAME
ANSWER I GOT FROM THE MAYOR OF
WARSAW, THE CAPITAL CITY TALKING
ABOUT A LONGER TERM PLAN.
ANDERSON, JUST TO GIVE A LITTLE
CONTEXT TO WHAT 2.5 MILLION
PEOPLE MEANS HERE IN POLAND,
THAT IS ONE UKRAINIAN FOR EVERY
15 POLS.
THAT IS AN ENORMOUS, ENORMOUS
NUMBER THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
ABSORBING.
THEY'RE ALL IN PRIVATE HOMES.
THEY ARE -- THEY ARE NOT IN --
THEY'RE IN REFUGEE CENTERS BUT
NOT HAVE VERY LONG.
SO IT'S STILL AN OPEN QUESTION
GIVEN THE FACT THAT EVERYBODY
ADMITS THAT THE WAR IS LIKELY TO
GO ON FOR SOME TIME.
HOW THESE MOSTLY WOMEN AND
CHILDREN ARE GOING TO GET THEIR
OWN PLACES, GET ALL OF THEM --
GET PROPERLY THE KIDS INTO
SCHOOL AND